sylia corn is blind she can't see colors
outlines or even light
but she can recognize them by using her
other senses and that
is how she chooses her subjects
when I'm alone I take pictures according
to the sounds the smell or the mood of
the setting for example now I can feel
the pavement that's a little different
so I'll take pictures of that
or that bird just now I want to capture
it in my photographs
as a child zeliha corn could still see
and she used a photograph and paint a
lot but that changed when at the age of
12 she lost her eyesight in a car
accident
it wasn't until she was in her 40s that
a professional photographer encouraged
her to start again by exploring the
world in her own way
but that's when I realized wow this
opens up a dialog between the sighted
and the blind it was so interesting that
I decided to continue I've been taking
pictures ever since
her husband often helps by telling her
what the things she touches and hears
look like
sylia Khan's pictures capture everyday
objects in a new light
she can also discern color using a
special sensing device for blind people
ah
you see it squeaks like that so it's
lighter
working with light is a special
challenge
and
we used different types of lamps I
was the model and tried to feel the
light on my skin you
can play a lot with a light and shadow
and I wanted to find out how to do that
in a controlled way but it's quite
difficult as a blind person
sylia con can't see the pictures she has
taken for that she needs the help of a
sighted person
it's gray here and white here and then
it narrows all the way down to here
it depends on how the person describes
it my husband has known me for so long
that he knows exactly what to say so
that I can picture it myself then it's
almost like seeing it with my own eyes
but there is no question about who
decides whether a picture should be
exhibited
well it's me ultimately she does there
her pictures
sometimes he tries to nudge me in a
certain direction but it mostly doesn't
work
the result is a window into Zelia Kahn's
view of the world